good evening welcome to Washington I'm
John Robertson from Bret bear this
Presidents Day Monday there are signs of
movement tonight on gun control in the
blistering reaction the last week school
shooting in Florida President Trump is
indicating he would be in favor of
efforts to improve federal background
checks for gun purchases this comes as
some of the survivors are making plans
to go to the State Capitol this week and
want march on Washington next month as
they demand change correspondent Steve
Harrigan starts this on us tonight from
parkland Florida good evening Steve John
good evening we got our first look at
the accused shooter in court today the
130 pounder was in a red jumpsuit
reserved for the most violent offenders
appearing in court today for another
motions hearing 19 year-old suspect
Nicholas Cruz kept his head down and
said nothing his public defender says
Cruz will plead guilty to 17 counts of
first degree murder in an effort to
avoid the death penalty
more anti-gun rallies were held at major
cities across the country young people
in Washington laid in front of the white
house demanding lawmakers intervened to
stop gun violence and students from
Stoneman Douglas High School where their
fellow classmates lost their lives have
announced plans for a national gun
control March in Washington set for
March 24th our elected officials need to
get together overcome their political
differences and get some things done
because they need to save the future of
our country
president Trump has scheduled a
listening session to meet with students
on Wednesday some survivors of the
shooting criticized Trump's weekend
Twitter attack on the FBI very sad that
the FBI missed all of the many signals
sent out by the Florida school shooter
this is not acceptable they are spending
too much time trying to prove Russian
collusion with the Trump campaign this
as the White House signals Trump would
back congressional efforts to strengthen
federal background checks for gun
purchases and Florida Senator Marco
Rubio urged state legislators to
consider so-called red flag laws that
enable family members
or law enforcement to have guns taken
away from someone deemed to be a threat
but the family Nicholas Cruz lived with
after the death of his mother last year
told ABC's Good Morning America they saw
no warning signs from Cruz everything
everybody seems to know we didn't know
we had rules and he followed every rule
to the team meantime the number of
warnings about Cruz that were missed
continues to grow information to the
social worker visited Cruz at home after
he posted pictures of himself on social
media cutting his arms and saying he
wanted a gun the social worker concluded
Cruz was a quote low-risk to harm
himself or others some students here are
still struggling to understand what
happened I was with meadow talking to
meadow right before you know the gunman
started shooting it's you know it is
very sad but at the same time like I
know that she's in a secret place now
and the angels will be with you
the school is expected to open at the
end of this week for teachers it's still
not clear when the students will return
John back to you Steve Harrigan in Fort
Lauderdale Florida for us tonight Steve
thanks so much